I think we can all agree that political
corruption is a bad thing and you don't
get more black and white in this regard
than the case of former Virginia
Governor McDonnell former Republican
governor of Virginia Bob McDonnell has
now been sentenced to two years in
prison 24 months that is how long Bob
McDonnell will spend in jail for
corruption charges last year at
McDonnell was convicted of accepting
gifts from a donor in exchange for
political favors this kind of personal
corruption quid pro quo stuff is what
we're used to seeing on television and
in film but simply we don't want those
in power our elected leaders to take
ethical shortcuts and we should but our
defenses are fragile
if personal corruption is the only kind
we recognize and protect ourselves
against unfortunately this is exactly
the case in the United States a little
over five years ago the Supreme Court in
the landmark decision of Citizens United
versus the FEC took up the argument
against structural corruption what
happens when the political system itself
is dependent on money from private
interests and found it won t last week
the Supreme Court reversed a century of
law that I believe will open the
floodgates for special
the majority decided that political
donations from however large and entity
are protected as a form of free speech
but does this misunderstand the way
politics actually works though there is
no explicit promise of legislative
favors for campaign donors politicians
remain indebted to their wealthiest
benefactors and this debt weaves its way
into policy decisions that consider the
needs of private interests over those of
the common
now the key argument against regulating
this kind of structural corruption is
that it's hard to determine where free
speech ends and political corruption
begins and that it may not be the courts
place to draw that line the premise is
freedom of speech the more speech the
better but by only recognizing something
for something personal corruption the
courts actually do draw a line and
abdicate themselves from the complex
interplay of money and politics I guess
most people who accuse American politics
of being corrupt do so because they see
an essential unfairness in the system
reflected in vast economic inequality
that's getting worse not better
as time goes on when the power of a
political campaign comes down to the
size of its coffers it's easy to see how
moneyed interests retain an improper
advantage and when that advantage serves
to worsen existing inequalities in the
system such politics are at least in
part structurally corrupt worst of all
structural corruption more so than
personal corruption perpetuates the idea
that individual people don't have a
voice in politics that putting the needs
of the Commonwealth first is impossible
and so it's pointless to try ironically
this kind of collective action
diminished by the free speech of wealthy
special interests is the only way to
protect democracy from the corrupting
influences that plague
hey everybody thanks for watching if you
want to support the nerd writer and help
me keep making these videos you can go
to patreon.com/scishow dried er and
pledge as little as one dollar anything
and everything helps thank you so much
for that if you have a patron award do
I'm gonna be sending those out promptly
so be on the lookout for that I'm not
the first person to talk about
structural corruption but I wanted to do
it my way I am passionate about the
topic and I want it more about it in the
future I just find it really interesting
and really important and vital and yeah
so follow me on tumblr and Twitter and I
will see you next time